at the end of time
[Music]
13. o'clock
well hey what's going on everybody it's
Wednesday night yeah it's time for the
regular ass show it's not a Regular Show
it's just it's the maid show the main
live show we don't have anything we
don't we don't have Regular Show yeah
everything's a little bit different we
just have irregular shows yeah
Tyler the guy says [__] yeah I love
Pirates now um honestly this was a
really interesting story because I don't
remember who it was that recommended
this topic it was a very long time ago
and I put it on the list and I kept you
know shuffling stuff around and it would
like show up in the poll every now and
then but it never won but then this past
time it finally did win and I didn't
hardly know anything about Grace
O'Malley and I think a lot of people
don't yeah um she's kind of like a big
folk hero in Ireland there's actually
even a statue of her in Dublin I believe
and it's fascinating to me because she's
just such a badass
character like she's just such a badass
person and it's kind of sad that a lot
of the [__] about her got lost I think
what happened was for whatever reason
um Irish historians kind of like erased
her from history for a little while for
various reasons which we'll talk about
uh in a bit
but uh she was so awesome apparently
that her Legend like lived on in
folklore
and actually there were like some
interactions between her and the English
which we'll also get into and the
English like so she turned up in all of
their records so she did exist and all
of that other kind of stuff like she was
a real person she was made up right yeah
yeah so so they do know like a lot of
stuff about her but the thing about it
that's interesting is that even stuff
that had come through in like folklorics
it was like all of these kind of like
songs about her and stuff like from
because she lived in um the 1500s
and they found out later on just from
various records and stuff that a lot of
the stuff that was like in folklore that
they're like oh that's made up and it's
like no that was that was probably true
yeah a lot of people don't realize it
but a lot of the things that you that we
grew up with believing is history were
made up
like uh like Marco Polo no he's made up
um the oldest book
and it's only very few Scholars that
know that Marco Polo has made up I think
it might be maybe it's out now
the oldest mention of Marco Polo is in a
fiction book and in that book they're
finding dog heads and [__] people
with faces on their chests and [__] like
that it was something for them it was a
science fiction book for the Middle Ages
like Star Wars
but there was no Marco Polo
wild huh yeah yeah and I always kind of
suspected like some people got mad I
suspected that Joan of Arc might have
been made up
but I think there's too much cooperating
evidence it's just
that tail just sounds too much like a
religious fable
but I guess she was real or at least
her existence was real I don't know if
all the stories about her were true well
I think that's kind of true of any
historical figure because especially uh
the farther removed you get from it it's
like you know the more people are gonna
and exaggerate or add to it or whatever
and I think that's definitely the case
with Grace O'Malley although like I said
they know for sure she did exist I mean
if anything she did meet with Queen
Elizabeth like there's records of that
uh and all that kind of stuff but there
was um you know she was came from like
um a very well-known clan in Ireland and
she wasn't just I mean you could dispute
because I think some people have
disputed like maybe calling her a pirate
because they're like well how much like
piracy did she actually do but I don't
know I kind of feel like a lot of the
stuff she did is absolutely could be uh
considered Pirates she it's weird
because she kind of came from oh thank
you Bryce this uh show always has high
quality content I've never heard of this
woman what a badass I love stories of
warrior women yeah uh this woman is uh
is pretty [__] cool I gotta say like
I said I didn't really know anything
about her these there have been a few
female pirates throughout history uh you
got Anne Bonnie uh Mary Reed I think she
was another one and the interesting
thing about Grace O'Malley though which
is actually the anglicized version of
her name
um and I'm not even really gonna attempt
to pronounce her
her original name which I think her
first name was actually pronounced
grania
as I think was how you pronounce it but
it's usually like anglicized says Grace
O'Malley like over here talking about it
because the [__] is hard to pronounce
you know what I mean like all their
names but the thing about her that was
interesting was that I kind of feel like
female pirates famous female pirates
like Anne Bonnie and stuff I kind of
feel like there was more of a thing
where they would usually like dress as
men or uh you know to get on board ships
and then they'd be all badass and stuff
she didn't really ever pretend to be a
man
um she actually grew up uh her dad was
also I guess you could call her dad a
pirate too but her dad her family was
like really really wealthy her dad was
like a Chieftain of the O'Malley Clan
which was like a big deal and they had
like a lot of land and a lot of cattle
and stuff like that so they were very
very well off and I think her mom was
well off to like their Clan so she came
from a wealthy background and she was
very educated but apparently from a very
young age uh she was super into
seafaring uh even when she was a little
girl and that's all she ever wanted to
do and so because she was her dad's only
child she did have a stepbrother I think
who was a little bit older but she was
like the only biological child
um I guess he kind of like indulged her
like he let her so he taught her to do
all this stuff like when she was a
little kid so she was like apparently
pretty [__] badass like as far as
like sailing and everything goes yeah
all the whole northern part of the UK
you know Scotland Ireland Wales
at this time they're about half Lawless
you could get away with a lot up there
they had laws but they were kind of
impotent and people were kind of
they were kind of wild man so I can
imagine that
a daughter of a wealthy person because
probably probably have free reign to the
place she could probably do whatever she
wanted
well it's kind of interesting would I
mean we'll get into this in a little bit
but the laws between and you know she
was kind of right in the middle of this
whole conflict like the nine years war
and all of that
um between the English and the Irish the
Irish had their own thing going on like
I said they were usually run by Clans
who had Chieftains so it was almost like
a warlord type of situation
um whereas the English had more kind of
like law like we would recognize
nowadays and the English during the time
that she was alive that Grace and Melly
was uh was alive were kind of
encroaching on the Irish and a lot of
the Irish didn't like it yeah um and so
she kind of got uh in the middle of all
that as well to straighten out this
whole cultural thing the northern the
northern regions of the British Islands
including Northern England
uh is pretty much the original red decks
that's where a lot of redneck cracker
culture came from that because they were
immigrating from there and coming into
the United States a lot of them in the
south
and a lot of Southern Culture kind of
Southern from the American point of view
a lot of Southern Culture has a Genesis
there in these Northern regions
and [__] that went
out of style in
in the British Islands ended up
continuing on in into uh you know even
the 1800s
early 1900s like certain how we used
English in certain English words and
what people consider slang a lot of
stuff came from Ireland or Wales
Northern England and uh so it's funny
uh you know I mean a lot of a lot of the
stuff that Southerners do is actually
dates back to these areas and they it
was wild it was wild man that's that's
uh it wasn't until much later the
northern regions became more
anglicanized they kind of uh started to
become more like England but that didn't
reach the South we even had Germans here
that spoke archaic versions of German
that long since died out back in Germany
uh so it's just that America was a weird
way to kind of fossilized certain
cultures
and um some of the like lawlessness of
the South actually kind of came from
these regions Ireland and [__]
yeah they're kind of uh mango saying um
yeah I guess he's talking about Irish
being kind of Lawless or whatever he
said they still are well yeah would it
make sense man they just got it in their
jeans you know me and Jenny if you're if
you're if you're an old-timey Southern
family you got a lot of Irish blood in
you and just you're under all these damn
pressures uh there were Lawless regions
uh [__] multiple multiple attempted
genocides against them they were trying
to wipe each other out too and all this
clan Warfare it just promotes [__]
psychopathy a real short tempers uh
disregard for order
really really independent you know it's
it's just
you can see it in southern cultures just
in people they you know it's hard to
tell them what to do
they're gonna tend to go nah I'm not
gonna do that you know
um
there's been some integration over the
decades but [__] my grandparents [__]
generation in the south
they were like something out of the
1700s 1800s man they did whatever the
[__] they wanted
Ben said feuds come from Irish tradition
yeah probably well and that's the thing
too is that one thing that the English
did when they were trying to essentially
like take over Ireland was they would do
the divide and conquer strategy where
they would try to like set The
Chieftains against one another it's like
hey if you [__] up this try this clan
over here like will give you all this
land and [__] like that so they were
trying to like set them against one
another yeah I don't want to make the
English look like a bad guys though they
had they were given they had a lot to
offer they they were good uh the English
were having the same problems with uh
with our people
that the Romans were having the Romans
couldn't handle them either
um
it was just the the nature of the Beast
they were
[__] they were they were they were
wild they didn't they were independent
they didn't want to be told what to do
yeah well like I said they each had
their own kind of thing going on and
they most most of the time I kind of
feel like they had that [__]
sorted out you know what I mean they
were just kind of like they had their
own code of conduct and they had their
own rules about [__] and they didn't
really like somebody coming in there and
telling them yeah to do something else
yeah you know and it even in Boston some
of the Irish neighborhoods that have
been there for [__] hundreds of years
they're like something out of the South
just more
more uh Urban but they're also High
blooded you'll fight
yeah yeah you know so the Italians but
the Irish are freaking
yeah man Fighters
yeah Bryce said I read that Irish and
Scottish Clans used to raid the cattle
of English Farmers yeah I don't doubt it
and the thing about it too is that
um Grace O'Malley and her family like
prior to that uh they did that also they
would kind of raid anybody though uh
anybody that came
Trucking by they're like hey you got new
[__] like whether it was from Spain or
anything like that another thing they
did which I thought was interesting and
I don't think I ever heard of any other
Pirates doing this I'm sure some of them
did was that they essentially made a
toll road you know what I mean so like
they would like when ships would come by
their territory they'd be like oh you
gotta pay up like or we'll take all your
[__] yeah like they'd let the people go
if they paid up but they they would
exactly you're going through their land
right yeah the Indians did the same
thing right if you went through Indian
Territory you broke their [__] you
broke their [__] uh uh their their
their borders you had to pay passage you
better give them something like I said
it's like or they'll just take
everything from you right like a toll
road because uh you know the Great
Plains area here in the United States is
kind of like the Open Sea you know what
I mean
except you're on horses but it was a lot
like this life on the sea there was
privacy and [__]
now we're gonna get into piracy
a lot of people kind of think Pirates
were criminals they weren't they were
privateers they were hired basically
hired mercenaries now other countries or
other kingdoms were consider to be
criminals for the [__] that they did to
their ships
and sometimes they would do stuff that
was illegal against their own countries
too so
but in general they were the contractors
they were kind of like the military
contractors of the day
it kind of lives on through American
culture
if you join the US Army you become a
private you're a private Soldier you're
being paid a mercenary basically and a a
pirate was a privateer he was being paid
a mercenary
so they're not really criminals
I mean some of them were but some of
them actually were sanctioned by their
government yeah you had to get a license
to do it like most famously Sir Francis
Drake yeah the
the country you served uh
I guess they were countries they were
more like kingdoms uh you know
and in a kingdom there wasn't really
kind of a concept of citizenry it was
just like a territory it was ruled by
Warlords and Kings but I guess
I guess you could call it a country
um
the borders tended to be kind of
malleable
but uh when you
when you became a or wanted to become a
pirate you had to go before the
officials and you had to buy a license
to do this and they would and if you
were working for England they would say
yeah you could raid the ships of France
and Spain but you got to give us a cut
you can't [__] with our ships
that's how it went you had to serve us
because they didn't have a big enough
Navy to do this and and these are
specialized skills these guys are like
[__] Commandos they're not trying to
sink a ship they're trying to steal a
ship the whole [__] ship if they
could
yeah they just want your [__] yeah now
in the movies they're always showing
these big like Spanish galleons
converted out to a narrass your pirate
ship now they use the thing called a
Sloop it was a lot smaller something you
could get up on a you could outrun a big
ship and then get on board of it with it
get on board and um you could board the
ship and fight your way in and usually
they use threats you know like
I don't know we might get we're going to
get into this later of how they did [__]
no you can talk okay
basically the first thing they did is
they'd come under a false flag usually
where they were flying a friendly flag
but then when they got up to them they'd
[__] pull the friendly flag down and
put a [__] Jolly Roger up and you
know each one or a pirate flag each one
had a different symbol on it you know a
devil with an hourglass with you know
that kind of stuff and it was threats
you know the longer you make us wait and
the more men we lose the more Savage
we're gonna [__] be to your crew when
we get on board
they really wanted to surrender without
a fight
um sometimes they did but they would do
things like try to destroy the sales of
the ship uh to bring it to a halt and
then they'd board it
and uh they were [__] psychos they
used a lot of psychological warfare
Edward Teach or Edward thatch you know
Blackbeard he was a good one and then
you had you had a he had a whole bunch
of other ones if I can uh [__] I'm
coming to what was the other guy's name
the guy that got elected some of them
got elected to be to be the pirate
captain and then against his will
because he was a navigator what was that
guy's name uh it doesn't matter now but
uh they were just uh
contractors military contractors at sea
and uh stealing [__] and given given
their King a cut
they were a lot of specialized skills
yeah the thing about Grace O'Malley like
I said there is kind of controversy over
whether you could technically call her a
pirate I guess you can kind of
technically call her a pirate because
she did do some pirate stuff but the
thing about it is that
for a long time Her Like official
biography or whatever I don't even think
that was written until like the late
1970s that's how kind of like obscure
she's not an obscure figure in folklore
but I think that people didn't really
know much about her real life until you
know later on even though it had been
preserved in uh English history but the
thing about it is that the reason why
Irish historians didn't write about her
at least for a long time is that they
had the perception which is a little bit
erroneous that she had cooperated with
the English crown during the nine years
war this is not entirely accurate I mean
she did meet with Queen Elizabeth and
she did like ask her for [__] and she
did promise her stuff
um but she didn't do the [__] that she
said she was gonna do and then like
later on she ended up like giving ships
I believe to the Irish Rebels so the you
know I kind of feel like she's a folk
hero in Ireland nowadays because she was
perceived as fighting for the cause of
Irish Independence which she did but it
was like indirect you know what I mean
like she did a lot of swashbuckly type
of stuff but she didn't actually
participate in the nine years war you
know what I'm saying but she did provide
ships for the rebels and things of that
nature and so she did seem to be
um you know sympathetic to their cause
even though she did the thing about her
was that she seemed like from everything
that I read about her she seemed like a
very shrewd
person I mean in the way that she kind
of knew I'm not gonna say she was just
out for her own self because I don't
think that's the case but she was just
really good at politics she was really
good at getting what she wanted she was
really good at
playing people against one another like
she was just really good at that kind of
stuff and she seemed like she was really
um respected like everybody that met her
men women everybody
um thought she was awesome you know what
I mean like just thought she was just
like this amazing amazing person so
and like I said there was songs written
about her there was all kind of [__]
even like years and years after she died
and she lived like quite a long life I
think she died and she was in her 70s
like she died in 1603 but you know well
we'll get into like some of the pirate
Seasons some of the stuff like I said is
they don't know if it's in 100 True
um but the same stories do keep coming
up uh and some of the stuff was
corroborated later on from like English
records so they do know that some of it
happened
but this was like I said all during the
mid to late 15th century is when all of
this uh stuff was happening
so
as I said Grace O'Malley who you know
like I said that's Grace isn't her first
name that's just her name is gronya
actually and so I guess we'll call her
that because that's what actually what
her name is but um she's kind of like
because uh you know like I said the
Irish historians had this perception
that she had
um collaborated with the English crown
which they didn't like and so they kind
of like wrote her out of History a
little bit and I think there was also a
perception that
uh because she was a woman and she was
doing [__] that women weren't supposed
to be doing back then
um they kind of didn't want to talk
about it either I will note though that
this was kind of interesting because I
didn't actually know this
but apparently in Irish law back then
and these laws go back to like way like
pre-middle ages like everything they
actually had laws and please correct me
if I'm wrong and this was the Irish the
English didn't have this as far as I
know but they actually had
um laws granting the woman like equal
status like she was seen as like the
husband's partner and not like property
you know what I mean because I feel like
in England and other parts of the world
you know you're if you married someone
you were like their property kinda and
Ireland apparently did not have that
however they did still have
um
they had kind of cultural things about
like what a woman was supposed to be
doing you know what I mean like you
weren't really supposed to be out
pirating or beginning to see well yeah
they did but I'm just saying that it's
like it was a little bit look to scans
at even though on paper you know they
were supposedly equal like it was more
egalitarian but they still like were it
kind of expected women still to like you
know marry and have children and do all
of that stuff like normal usually to get
on a part to become part of a pirate
crew you'd had to have a military
background usually you learned like say
in one of the royal navies it might be
the British Navy or French Navy or
Spanish Navy that's usually where you
started
but then later you'd become a contractor
and well the the Royal navies were
[__] strict it was men only brutal
discipline
um they were [__] you know they were
Savage they would kill dudes at sea for
pretty minor [__] and kill hauling
people and stuff
the uh
the pirate Crews were kind of against
that because they went through that
already they didn't want to put up all
that [__] all right they had
discipline like you weren't supposed to
fall asleep while you're on duty
technically you weren't supposed to be
drinking on duty but they did that oh
yeah everybody yeah
um
and they were real lacks about having
women
they kinda
in general pirate a pirate crew would
claim not to have any women but if you
looked at him you'd see women in there
they'd just be kind of dressed in guys
clothing all right and it was because
dudes wanted to go to see with their
girlfriends wouldn't you you know and uh
some girls were
ladies of the evening there were women
from Port and they got sick of that life
they wanted to [__] go out to sea
adventure and they could still apply
their trade at sea too and double dip so
they're getting a cut of the booties
what it's called and the other guys are
getting a cut of the booty too but they
gotta pay you know so there was that
[__] going on too I mean why when you
think about it if you're practical and
you're a and you're a a privateer
and you're out there raiding ships why
wait to go back to Port
to get a prostitute why not have them on
board yeah I mean there's no rules or
nothing you're already a pirate yeah so
they just do what the [__] you want
right so they would get they would hold
fun girls that would kind of do a
purpose that could work on the ship and
and as a pirate and as a pirate pirate
squeeze you know what I mean they did
that too uh although most common it was
I think Calico Jack had two of his
girlfriends on there with him
and I think they started out I think his
name is Calico Jack I think
uh some some of you guys that might know
this
I think because he wore that damn uh he
dressed up he was quite a Dandy I think
his name was Calico Jack
um he had two of his girlfriends with
him and uh they started off dressing as
guys but they just said [__] it they
just started wearing women's dresses
like pirate women dresses in front of
the crew the crew liked them anyway they
didn't care everybody knew
I think that's I think that's how that
went
a long time since I read those books
Bryce said I don't see anything wrong
with her cooperating with the crown if
she did her priority is her clan and no
one else yeah the thing about it like I
said I think that's why it's a little
unfair to say that she cooperated with
the English crown she did she didn't
really I mean she really just did it to
like we'll get into it a little bit but
there was this one [__] that was
actually like under Queen Elizabeth that
was after her and actually imprisoned a
couple of her sons and she actually just
went to Queen Elizabeth saying like hey
tell that dude to like knock that [__]
off and she was basically like hey I'll
give you all these ships and all this
other stuff like if you help me out and
Elizabeth said yeah but she never gave
him any ships or nothing yeah I mean I
think she just promised that like to get
what she wanted like I said
the interesting thing is when she met
Queen Elizabeth like Queen Elizabeth
seemed like they were about the same age
I think Queen Elizabeth was a little bit
older than her they were both in their
50s at the time and I think Queen
Elizabeth was fascinated by her because
she everybody knew who she was she was
quite famous like in her day and so you
know she was quite legendary so I feel
like Queen Elizabeth was just like
fascinated to meet her you know what I
mean so it was this really kind of
interesting
meeting of these two kind of like
legendary women it was just kind of like
like I said they were both in their 50s
at that point but it was just really
interesting so uh so yeah so I think
part of the reason was again because
she didn't really conform to the and the
thing about it too was that she came
from a wealthy background she came from
like she was a chieftain's daughter and
there were certain expectations that
went with that she did meet some of
those expectations like she did Mary
like she was supposed to and she had
kids and all that other kind of stuff
but she just seemed like she just wanted
to be a Seafarer she wanted to
you know Captain a ship and she wanted
and she did it and the thing so she just
and it seems like her dad was okay with
it like he was just like yeah just do
what the [__] you want yeah I was
correct his name is John John Rackham
also known as Calico Jack
uh he was most remembered for having two
female crew members her name was Mary
Reed and Anne Bonnie yeah yeah that's
the way I just mentioned but yeah both
of them yeah and I'm that now if I
remember correctly they ended up in um
it was either Cuba or Puerto Rico
and they were Facing The Gallows and I
think the girls got off because they
were pregnant or at least claimed they
did yeah they got off yeah
yeah both of them can't because I was
actually going to mention them a little
bit because those are like probably the
most famous female pirates yes we got
but yeah they were gonna hang them but
then they they were both Ben's in there
saying oh [__] they didn't everybody
knew that women were bad luck no pirate
ships had women on them
they didn't give they didn't give a [__]
they were bad luck themselves nobody was
they said they would say [__] like the
the you know that they weren't even
afraid of the devil
you know that the devil was afraid of
them you know they didn't care about bad
luck
dudes were [__] tough
they were the worst luck of all times
[Laughter]
that's pretty funny yeah although he did
mention that a lot of it had to do with
crew members getting getting getting
revenge on on the ships that they used
to work on that was part of the thing
yeah because there was a big class
system in in the naval system back then
and you were like [__] those dudes man
just steal their [__]
yeah
so uh okay so as I mentioned Grace
O'Malley or grania as we're calling her
because that's what her name is
her dad uh was named Owen O'Malley that
is also the anglicized version because
I'm not even going to attempt to
pronounce what his actual name is
so he was the chieftain like I said of
the O'Malley Clan uh of CR of clue Bay
which is County Mayo and uh apparently
he had unlike a lot of the Irish Clans
um the O'Malley's were very uh into
seafaring like they're pretty much their
entire
um wealth and stuff like that had come
from seafaring their entire living came
from
seafaring uh they even had the motto of
the O'Malley Clan uh was in Latin Terra
marike potens powerful by land and sea
that's what they called it
so um they were so she came from like a
long line of seafarers the O'Malley Clan
had long been seafarers going back a
long way and that's how they pretty much
made their Fortune they would go and
raid you know Scotland Spain they would
go all over the place and just rage [__]
like I said so they had like a lot of
land
now um as I said there's some debate
over whether they could be called
Pirates or not but I kind of feel like
you know yeah they they do have records
that they and there were actually like
folklore that was later backed up with
records that they did actually plunder
as far as Spain and things like that so
yeah I guess you could technically call
them Pirates and as I said they would
also do the thing where they would if
you came through their territory they
would make you pay you know what I mean
it's like a toll road type situation
they would call pain grift wouldn't it
or tariff or I think it was called grift
or something grass something like that
um but yeah it's so it's interesting
because Grace O'Malley grania she
actually later on became known as the
pirate Queen uh of England even though
like I said it's debatable whether she
was a pirate or not but you know as she
did some pirate stuff so I'm gonna let
it slide now as I said she did have
um an older stepbrother I don't actually
know if anybody knows what his name was
but
um but she was her parents pretty much
like their only uh biological child
now I don't know I've heard two stories
about this
um either that the father raised her as
a boy
or didn't really do that but just kind
of said well you know you can do
whatever the [__] you want like it
doesn't matter that you're a girl you
know what I mean
um whether it was either of those two
things it kind of like amounts to the
same thing I guess now interestingly
because she was the daughter of a
Chieftain one thing that they would do
uh normally and they don't actually know
if granya actually did this or not but
they said in Ireland like if you were
the child of a Chieftain or the daughter
of a Chieftain you would usually get
sent out to be educated like with
another clan like a under another
Chieftain like they would educate you
and then you would come back you know
what I mean so I don't know if she
actually did that but they do know that
she was actually quite educated
um which like more like more than a girl
would be at the time uh they know that
she spoke Gaelic they know that she
spoke Latin
um and they said probably she also spoke
French and Spanish because she was very
well traveled and that was where they
did a lot of their seafaring or piracy
or whatever so they said she probably
spoke those languages as well
I don't know if she could actually write
but she could speak several languages
so apparently The Story Goes that when
she was a little girl I've heard that
she was maybe 10 or 11 or something like
that
she wanted to go with her dad uh he was
gonna go to Spain I think like to do
some kind of I don't know if he was
doing piracy type of stuff but he was
just doing like a seafaring Mission or
whatever and she really wanted to go and
she was still a little girl
and he didn't really want her to go
because I guess you know she's still a
kid so he's like no so I think the
excuse that he gave her was like well
you can't go because your long hair will
get caught up in the rigging yeah and
apparently she was like defiantly picked
up a knife and cut off all of her hair
she knew he was bullshitting
so then like after that they called her
um I think in in Gaelic or whatever or
Irish it's grania
uh whale which means bald Grace or bald
ground yeah like that's what they called
her and she's still known as that like
sometimes
um they don't know if she cut off all
her hair or just cut it like super super
short yeah she probably just bobbed it
yeah and her dad like thought that was
he just thought that was so funny I
guess or so badass that he's like okay
you can come with so she did actually
end up going
so um yeah so the thing about it is that
she grew up from a very young age on
ships uh so she learned everything about
ships about navigation
um she was taught to fight
um pretty much everything like from what
when 11 on
now as I said uh she was still expected
to marry a lot of the Clans would marry
you know like a lot of the kind of big
up families did like you know for
political reasons
and that's uh generally what happened
with her first marriage now she got
married when she was oh it's Pookie yeah
Pookie's getting heavy
you're getting heavy that's a play way
of saying you're getting fat don't tell
her that you're gonna give her a complex
look at she's making a mad face
she's like shut up Daddy
but yeah um so she was 16 or 17.
and she married her first husband whose
name was Donald O'Flaherty Flagerty
um now this was like um the O'Flaherty
Clan was another kind of seafaring Clan
and they were also allies of the
O'Malley's obviously
now uh she by the time she was 16 she
was already a very uh Adept sailor
and over the course of their marriage uh
they were only married I think maybe
eight years something like that she
actually ended up having they had three
children together uh two sons whose name
were Owen and Murrow and also had a
daughter named Maeve
uh and then her first husband and this
is going to be a running theme but her
first husband was out hunting
and he got ambushed and murdered by
another Irish Clan the Joyce Clan yeah
they did that kind of [__] because they
did that kind of [__] like I said this
will be a running theme like if that
happened to like a lot it feels wild out
there I guess you can't even go [__]
hunting man there's that [__]
yeah
Bad Blood yeah so I don't know what he
did to piss off the Joyce Clan but they
got back at him what is so he just uh
got [__] murdered through all that
Hatfield McCoy [__] [__] came from
that was here at the U.S look at Pookie
she's like sitting there for a really
long time Sammy goes Pokey yeah look at
her I sent in Austell what a good girl
you're being she's trying to go off this
way she's like trying to fall down and
get off huh she's like I don't know I
can't decide she's like he's sticking
her head in her face and she's like yeah
now she likes a rubber nose on me yeah I
mean she does like for you wiping her
nose a cold ass [__] nose she likes
to do that on my feet for some reason
like I'll be like sitting on my desk and
not see her and then like all of a
sudden this cold little nose like on My
Feet
so yeah so her husband Donald gets
murdered right
and then the Joyce Clan are like they
have an idea they're like oh well the
hubby's dead so we're gonna go and take
Donald's Castle because nobody's there
now except for the little woman and the
and the kids you know what I mean
guess what Grace O'Malley whipped their
asses like they came and like tried to
take the [__] castle and uh she was
not having it she uh actually her and
her men they uh she fought them back I
heard yeah security I heard that she
actually uh melted down like some lead
and [__] like that and the castle just
dumped it on them like when they came up
I don't know if that's true or not but
that was one like source that takes a
while yeah so I don't know if she knew
they were coming and she was like oh I'm
gonna give these [__] they'll
never forget uh they would have had
Firearms I think
yeah this was uh she was born in 1530
yeah the only one had match locks so
this was when she was
um I think maybe in her maybe 20. so
this is about 1550 somewhere around
there 15 50 15 55.
um but yeah so
apparently the uh the counter attack was
so Fierce that they were just kind of
like okay never mind and the castle
today
is still known as hens Castle because
she was protecting her children like a
mother hen I heard also that this might
have been because her husband Donald who
was murdered obviously
um was called the [__] yeah
um
either because either because he was an
[__] or because he just like ran
around [__] anything that moved right
or it could be both both those things I
guess
um so I guess like jokingly like the
people in the area would call it Cox
Castle but after she fought back the
Joyce Clan and ran them off then they
started calling it hens castle and as
far as I know they still call it that
nowadays which I thought was very funny
yeah scholarly acts and reading books
and long-term planning that really
wasn't in your advantage if you were a
man living in that area at that time
what
guaranteed your success is you had to
exude a lot of masculinity you had to
[__] be fearsome yeah and uh
evidently she can hang with the man
well yeah and the interesting thing
about it is that even after Donald died
all of his men
um she moved to
um like uh Claire Island which is kind
of where they set their base up I don't
know if there was already a like a manor
house or a castle there or if she had
one built or whatever but she moved
there with her family and all of
Donald's men went with her yeah and they
remained loyal to her like the rest of
her life that was actually a lot more
common than people think there were
dudes were loyal to Queens evidently
Queen Isabella was the [__]
all everybody loved her guys were really
willing to [__] die for
um evidently we're real good looking but
uh no the female leadership was [__]
common
yeah it's usually not a [__] what was
that Mad Max movie Beyond Thunder Dome
remember [__] Auntie yeah took him it
was that kind of situation
Tina Turner yeah it was good that was
good that was a good but she seemed to
like even at this age because she was
still pretty young at this point um you
know I think she was only in her maybe
in her 20s early 20s
um she already commanded the respect of
like all this I believe it was 200 men
and uh they came with her like wherever
she went like subsequently women know
how to charm dudes and get loyalty out
of
well she like I said she knew how to do
that yeah she was very good at didn't
want to let her down she likes me
[Laughter]
I could probably give him some out too
well I don't know about that but well
she was kind of like women would have to
be [__] strategic with what she does
yeah she was that that's a good way of
putting it she was very very strategic
yeah
um and like I said she seemed I don't
know if I'd say Charming or something
like that but she definitely knew how to
get her way and she knew how to like
without being an [__] about it
because nobody said she was a [__] or
nobody said no I read that yeah I I kind
of feel like everybody was like admired
her like she was just like a very
admirable
uh person probably just real reasonable
May yeah some of the best bosses I
worked for were women
yeah they're just reasonable yeah you
know there wasn't an ego Clash yeah you
know because you do get that a lot of
times
yeah dude yeah he's the [__] main
dude and some of the guys underneath him
they might be Rivals to him you know
that might be better yeah they start
stronger they're like I gotta get this
dude killed if not he'll take over right
so there's that kind of [__] because I
feel like women get a bad rap of like oh
those [__] and they're always like
backfighting and everything I think
dudes are worse than that right yeah
guys are worse I mean I'm not saying
women don't do it too because they do
but I'm just saying that I think dudes
are worse
like the way it depends put jockey for
position it depends on the type of
people that you're talking about right
and the type of situation that it is I
mean it's just like everything else like
everything a lot more complicated than
than whatever
but um but yeah so she goes to this
castle and she's got like all of
Donald's men who stayed with her like
pretty much forever
um she also had a [__] ton of ships I
believe she had 20 ships
um I also heard a story that her
favorite one
she actually had the Rope
from the ship go all the way up to the
window of her bedroom and she had it
like tied around the around her bed post
so that if somebody tried to take it
like she'd be like what the [__] quit
touching my ship just like just her
favorite one I don't know if that's true
but that's like another story that I
heard I'm like Ah that's awesome but
yeah because I guess they were like
right on the sea like where all there's
like right on the bay like where all
their ships were
now uh so yeah so
they use these ships obviously for you
know exacting tribute you know
collecting tolls things like that and
also uh piracy and this is about where
uh her epithet of the pirate Queen name
came about
now in around this time or a little bit
before this uh her dad Owen O'Malley had
died
and it so happened that she essentially
Rose to the rank of Chieftain of the
O'Malley Clan I don't know how common
that was
um usually the thing about it I was
watching a video about this earlier and
they said normally you know in in the
English system you know they would have
the royal families and it was usually
like the oldest son would automatically
like inherit the title or whatever
whereas in Ireland it was more
um Democratic I guess like they would
actually like elect
the chieftain rather than it just being
de facto like this person because they
were the kid of the chieftain before
so I don't know if she just Rose to the
ranks because she was the only child the
only biological child of the chieftain
or because she was elected like
everybody wanted her to be Chieftain but
she did actually become Chieftain of the
of the clan like after that so like I
said I'm not really sure how common that
was for
for a woman to have that uh position
um and so
this is another interesting thing too so
at this point
um she did marry again later but I guess
she's single at this point where she's
widowed I guess we'll say that
Story Goes that uh close by where her
castle was
there was a shipwreck and she said I'm
gonna toddle on down there and see if
they got anything I can swipe you know
what I mean she's a pirate
so she's gonna go check it out
so she goes down there and she finds a
sailor who is apparently injured but is
still alive
and uh apparently they're like hey hey
and apparently they started a thing do
you know what I mean like I said she was
single at this point she was widowed
it's fair
um but yeah so the two of them
um were lovers for quite a while uh it's
also rumored that she had an
illegitimate son by him but I don't know
if that's the case or not
they're um but again as I said
this is going to be a running theme he
was also murdered by another clan the
McMahon's uh I guess I don't know what
he did to piss off the McMahon's but
they saw him walking out he said look at
that [__] I hate that
[__] so they went and killed
that guy too so she's like man she's
like zero for two at this point it's
like gang war for me that's exactly what
it is yeah she's like man that was a hot
piece of dick right there and it's like
they just [__] it up they just stopped
walking down the beach it was like get
that [__] and it's like yeah
that's that's how it happened it's a
long time ago we can talk about her like
that but yeah I don't know how upset she
was like I said but I just I just love
the story like I said I don't know if
it's true or not but I just love the I
love the story about her like going down
to check out you know whatever was in
the Shipwreck to see if she could like
salvage some [__] and then seeing like a
dude laying there and being like hey
that's the best thing on here yeah I'm
gonna take this home with me but yeah so
it seems like she was kind of like that
but uh yeah
so uh apparently she was uh pretty mad
about the McMahon's killing her uh a
little bit on the side here because when
she found out who had killed the dude
she went and tracked them all down at
Duna Castle
and killed them right back yeah she
wiped him out she killed uh she killed
the two I don't know how many dudes it
was but she killed him
she was mad yeah um so yeah so she went
in there I was mad she's mad I was mad
and uh this event actually she got a
nickname
the dark Lady of Duna because doona was
the name of the castle where she went in
there and like rubbed the dudes out
probably killing her night for killing
her boyfriend yeah right nighttime raid
yeah which still I mean
like I said she's pissed off don't get
on her bad side is what I'm saying well
they deserved it yeah I mean that was a
shitty thing to do McMahon Clan yeah
geez
so then around
1566 or 1567 she married again uh this
dude she married him mostly for her
strategic purposes like political
reasons uh they don't seem to have been
like in love or anything although they
did seem to be like good friends and
good partners like which we'll get into
in a minute his name was Richard Burke
uh he was known as iron Richard not
probably for the reasons you might think
but it was actually it was actually for
kind of a boring reason because he owned
an Ironworks but that's why
um yeah so he was a Chieftain also in
the Burke Clan obviously
and he was actually
um going to inherit a bunch of land and
he had a bunch of money and the land
that he was inheriting was like
strategic like she wanted it so that's
why she married him as well
now what they did and I guess I don't
know how common this was at the time
either like you know I've seen sources
that said this was pretty common but
like I said I don't know how true that
is
so apparently
um grania and iron Richard
they did a trial marriage which I guess
was something you could do back then
which this is actually like a good idea
where they would get married for a year
and then like if they decided that at
the end of the year they didn't like
each other then they'd be like all right
[__] off and you [__] off and then they
just like they just go their separate
ways and it's all fine I heard about
that which like I said seems like a good
that's like yeah like a trial marriage
that's a good idea yeah it's like Dayton
right but like we're moving in again but
more official right yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is moving in together is what it is
yeah pretty much
um but yeah so and then after that like
you could annull it or if you decided to
stay married it's like okay fine you're
like married now forever
telling you manage people who are more
reasonable than you think they were I
mean yeah they like I said reading about
especially like the Irish even though
they have the reputation for being like
these crazy like rebellious everything
but it's like some of the laws that they
had I'm like well that sounds like a
good idea yeah and it was a hodgepodge
it just depending on where you were and
when there's you know people would
people weren't always [__] uptight
you know
yeah I kind of feel like yeah depending
on where you were a lot of times people
were
pragmatic yeah I kind of feel like I was
here I I heard some stuff that uh some
historians were saying that even during
the time of the Spanish Inquisition in
Spain or tokomata and everything
that that
they weren't that that they weren't that
crazy that um a lot of other people were
like man this acquisition [__] you know
that's [__] you know and evidently
you could you could get away with quite
a bit you know it wasn't like the church
could just kill you or torture you they
had to have explicit [__] that they
needed to do
and evidently in in the Inquisition most
of it was [__] just trying to talk
somebody into converting into into the
Catholicism he didn't do anything to
them
it was just it's parts of it were kind
of blown up into something that it
wasn't but evidently it was even in
Spain people thought it was [__] it
was mostly happening I think in one city
where that was happening
so I just it's just uh you know
history kind of focuses in on one little
chapter but they don't give you the full
[__] picture of what everybody
thought about it and they're like hey
you know this has only really happened
in one city
I talked about this many times is that
from a historical standpoint like
everything is so complicated
um you're only really gonna get a
limited part of the picture because
you're only getting the perspective of
people who actually wrote [__] down or
you know recorded stuff that happened
you're not getting like the mass opinion
of
you know the the unwashed masses who
couldn't read or anything like that like
I said you know using that for an
example maybe when that was going on
maybe most people thought it was
[__] and hated it evidently but they
couldn't write they couldn't you know so
their opinions have been forgotten or
lost then we generalize the Middle Ages
a lot uh there were certain places that
were pretty good in the Middle Ages uh
also I heard that during the late Middle
Ages there were evidently pretty good uh
the food quality is pretty good
sanitation was it was a lot better it
was almost kind of like the Renaissance
during the late Middle Ages but like I
said it depending on where you were
yeah that kind of yeah depends on a lot
of things well even nowadays it's like
you know how good your life is yeah
that's gonna depend on where you get
born or didn't it I mean you know
there's still a lot of shitty places in
the world
so and it was I'm sure the same back
then same back then and not just uh you
know the environment that you lived in
but it was also like the people that
were around you like some people were
cool and some people yeah some cities
were cool and some cities weren't but I
was I heard that from his Summer Stories
were saying that late Middle Ages some
of those cities were quite mentally
Advanced you know they were they were
pretty scientific they didn't have
science down but they were open to
science you know what I'm talking about
they were yeah the beginnings of
scientific thinking and you could
basically speak your mind and not have
to worry about getting your head shot
yeah it just depends on what city you
were in yeah
well I've always been fascinated by the
Renaissance period and the enlightenment
period just because it was such a
culmination of you know I I think people
nowadays because it was so long ago tend
to think of like the Renaissance of the
Enlightenment is like one thing that
happened it's like oh suddenly everybody
was no smart and like piecemeal but yeah
but that it had been building up to that
for like a really long time and it just
kind of like flowered out into but you
know there had been people
saying that kind of [__] for like a long
time prior to that it's just that it
didn't really hit that attention Middle
Ages say that [__] there were aliens
on other planets and the stars were the
Suns it killed his ass for that they did
yeah what was his name Giovanni or
something Jordan Bruno yeah we should do
a show about him yeah and he was trying
to convince her but those I read a
couple books about him he's a
fascinating man what they did to that
dude was [__] up he would they
wouldn't he wouldn't back off of it he's
like no the stars are other sons and
there could be other people around there
they said what they got him on was like
a type of blasphemy they were saying so
what you're saying
is that on those other planets
in order to save their souls God must
have made other jesuses and he's like
yeah so so you're seeing more than one
Mary I guess so multiple jesuses and
then too much that was too much for them
so they couldn't handle it so our Jesus
isn't special it's just one of the
millions of Jesus is out there okay You
Gotta Die
yeah they like nailed his lips together
he wouldn't back off of it though which
I think he's crazy so now you're right
yeah yeah I'm just I'm just talking out
of it well that's what I mean he really
was in he's like no I'm serious he's
like no man
yeah I read a couple books about him and
it's like the [__] that he said because
I read some of his writing stuff like
that that blew my [__] mind I'm like
holy crap it was way ahead of his time
you're right well here's the thing it
couldn't have been just him
nobody works in isolation especially
like nothing like that there must have
been a group of people or just people
that were even separate people that were
thinking the same thing and they were
going because that's usually how it
happened yeah it's never just one person
that comes up with something yeah it can
only mean that there was enough evidence
out there in there in their in their
[__] sphere to where you could put
that together that we're on a planet
around a [__] around a star and those
other stars have other planets around
them because they you know they had a
model of the solar system
so they were going like we're not that
special and that's my the church wasn't
having that no we are special shut up
yeah right yeah well I'm sure there's a
lot of people educated people are like
yeah this is we're not that special
we're on a rock
okay around the Sun
this isn't a big deal you know and they
weren't going to church wasn't gonna
have that because that would take all
their power away
yeah they had all that money and all
that power they weren't gonna come out
and say well well you know
RCA is kind of [__]
Wall Street wouldn't do that the Federal
Reserve Bank wouldn't do that they're
gonna [__] keep the scam going well
if a few years ago I read a book there's
a great book called free thinkers which
is actually about it's essentially it's
about atheism or like people that had
atheistic ideas going back like
thousands of years
um and that's like really if you read
like some people's oh man that works
right like from thousands of years ago
it sounds very modern yeah like a lot of
the [__] they were saying and like you
said it's the same kind of stuff like
the same criticisms of religion and
stuff like that that you would hear
nowadays so it's you know it's not new
any of that stuff a Greek or a Roman you
could cut them loose today if you teach
them English they'd [__] understand
everything they'd be using a computer
and a phone in [__] a few days
they you know yeah we were talking about
that the other day like if you could
bring somebody from any time period like
to the modern day and how long it would
take them to acclimate and I said well I
guess it would depend on what part of
the world they came from and it would
depend on like what era they came from
yeah I feel like the Greeks and Romans
would probably get up to speed like
pretty quick and you know like I said
more more recently like people for the
enlightenment they probably like only
take a week or so on there in Egyptian
it might take them a little bit longer
um
because they they didn't never even seen
steam power before
although they were pretty [__]
advanced
they had they had they had a
hieroglyphic alphabet so it'd be easier
to teach them in alphabet
and then as soon as they saw what was
possible you know they were the kind of
people especially if they were educated
they'd be the kind of people they
couldn't deny reality they'd be like
okay yeah
this is human progress they would
understand that immediately
how long has this been [__] six
thousand years five thousand years okay
yeah this one that checks out you know
because
Egyptians had a grasp of time
I always wondered what it would be like
if you got like an ancient Egyptian and
could bring them here in a time machine
and then like show them that like the
Sphinx and [__] was still there
and the like people were going to be
impressed like oh yeah they'd be like
holy [__] that's still there you let
that [__] [__] you blew it up damn it
that's what I mean they'd probably be
mad that looks so nice
[Laughter]
everybody knows that knows that that's
really very famous but it's like that's
that would be super funny like I wonder
what they would say they would that's
actually what I was thinking that's
probably exactly what they would say
that we messed up it's like well it
doesn't look as good as they used to
like when I was yeah when I was a kid
you know what I mean 3 000 years ago 4
000 years ago whatever it was I think
the Egyptians would have figured it out
an elite Mesoamerican or Elite an elite
Mayan
you know like an Aztec priest one that
was studying the calendar
could uh would have the intellect to
figure it figure out modern modern
technology
it'd be mind-blowing to them though
they'd be worrying about the blood debt
what's the blood debt for the blood debt
wasn't real oh [__]
cutting out all those hearts for nothing
you know yeah either that or he'd be
like I need to cut some hearts out right
now yeah but I'm way behind the sun's
gone
the sun's gonna burn out and catch up
thank you very much Jeffy art all
throughout time I'm sure there were a
lot of smart non-religious folks who
just laid low and kept their heads down
yeah yeah I'm sure they did because well
and especially back during certain time
periods when you could get [__]
burned at the stake for that [__] you
might as well you might want to keep
your mouth shut and just kind of like
play along you know what I mean I don't
blame anybody for doing that they were
playing along most of them if you asked
me I kind of feel like probably most of
them are
you know
I don't know if a lot of them may
believe that [__] well the thing about
it was that especially something like
during the Middle Ages and stuff one a
lot of those people were illiterate and
two it's I kind of feel like they just
had their own lives to worry about I
mean their lives were probably not all
that long and we're kind of like
difficult so I imagine they were just
worrying about like [__]
you know their crops and that kind of
crap they weren't really worried about
kids yeah they were worried about more
practical concerns that's what I that's
what I meant when I said most people
were probably like pragmatic you know
what I mean because like they got Life
to Live they got [__] to do they can't
just fart around worrying about shoes
had holes in them they're worried about
new pair of shoes right that kind of
thing yeah which I I feel like that's
true in any era yeah most people just
have their own problems and
have their own lives to live and don't
really think about like larger ideas or
whatever
uh Ben said that happened in Highland
the Highlander TV show when Nefertiti
was in Paris and saw the Luxor obelisks
and she was really confused and said she
used to be able to see them at her
window back home in 300 BC yeah we moved
that [__] sorry
[Laughter]
I'm here
but yeah so oh one thing I forgot to
mention it wasn't in my notes but I um
heard it on another documentary that I
was watching about Grace O'Malley was
that one thing when she was a a kid
still like when she was a teenager
because remember I said that she started
out on her dad's ship like going out on
uh you know raids and stuff with him
and one story was that um this one like
this other uh like a rival guy like came
on the ship and like her and her dad
like him and the dad fought
and the dad like kind of bested him for
a second but then he told uh Grande he's
like hey go downstairs because she was
just a little kid still and he's like
just you know go down to the whatever
and then um you know just get out of the
way while we're fighting and so she sees
it happen but then she climbs up to
um the she climbs up on the rigging or
whatever and then she sees the guy or a
different guy like is and he's gonna
like stab her dad like in the back and
she jumped down and killed the dude
so I don't know if that's true or not
but that's another story that I heard
about her and that's when she was like a
teenager then I forgot to mention that
when I was talking about her like her
childhood or whatever so okay so we got
distracted again but
so remember how we were saying like in
Ireland you could do the trial marriage
thing
so she marries iron Richard right
and then so a year goes by and then he
goes off to do some [__] or whatever and
then he comes back home
and when he comes back home so The Story
Goes
Grace or grania had changed the locks on
his castle
and
she like so he comes up the the driveway
or whatever you call it and uh she leans
out the window and basically says you
are dismissed
which I thought that was so funny but it
couldn't have been as bad as that
because he actually like they did annul
the marriage
um but they stayed friends and they
stayed like Partners like they still
ditch it because I think under English
law they were still considered married
but under Irish law they weren't if if
I'm like reading that correctly
but um so I guess she I guess he wasn't
too bad but see but that that's crazy to
me she must have been cool because to do
that kind of cold-hearted [__] it's like
he comes back oh hi honey I'm home and
she's like [__] you you're not coming
back in this Castle [__] and
she's like changed all the locks and is
like yeah get the [__] out of here and
then he's still like ah you're still my
buddy though like that's crazy but so
she must have been cool but yeah
um so the two of them actually did have
a son together
and his name was Tibbett his name is
Tibbett
Toby Toby of the ship that was what his
name meant
now the story about him this is pretty
badass too the story about him goes why
he was called Toby of the ship
is because he was apparently born
on uh a ship like while his mom was
obviously like a captain it was the
thing
now according to the legend either a few
hours after he was born or the day after
he was born
her ship was attacked by Algerian
Pirates
now grania was down in the hold or
whatever they call it with the baby
and her men were like fighting off the
Pirates and she could hear up there
she's like I think they're getting their
asses kicked maybe I should like go help
out so she's so it's either been like a
few hours after she's given birth or the
day after she's giving birth she grabs
her [__] swords and goes up there and
helps them fight the Pirates yeah after
she gave birth well she's not gonna let
the Pirates have the baby well no yeah
that's what I mean you don't [__] with a
with a mom and the kid
so uh so yeah she's basically going up
there and uh helped her dudes and they
fought the Algerian Pirates off and uh
so then she just like wolf I've got we
got that over with so then they just
went back home
to have babies and lay around for
[__] five six months after back in
the old days those girls would give
[__] birth in the middle of a rice
paddy and throw the baby in the back
they were fighting to go right back to
picking rice just throw it in the back
to back throw in a backpack
boy that was good well it's not it's not
like they really had much choice I mean
it's not like
[__] it Gotta Fight The Pirates
she's like gosh damn it yeah somebody
watched like don't let them roll off the
cot or whatever I'm gonna go up and kick
these Pirates asses but uh yeah that's
[__] crazy I mean she's probably just
like oh God just like I can't imagine
she's all torn up and [__] because yeah
that tears her [__] up
so I don't know what I don't know what
they did before well they died in
childbirth a lot of times that's what
they did
um before the Advent of modern medicine
so there was that yeah that's the
numbers on that were pretty good though
too the chances of dying a childbirth
weren't that weren't that good your
chances are you you survived a lot you
know well like I said it depended on
where you were yeah because a lot of
midwives knew how to do stuff they could
turn her baby around and they're reach
an intern and they actually knew to like
wash their [__] hands yeah like that
which a lot of doctors didn't figure
yeah until like later on so um
putting their stinky ass fingers all up
in there
gross but evidently and I think most
women throughout history just kind of
squat down and [__] squeeze that out
on them
I want a blanket although I will I will
note that a lot of women did die in
childbirth a lot of women do yeah and
even like wealthy women that presumably
had okay great yeah a lot of things can
go wrong I mean [__] women still die in
childbirth nowadays and we have
look at this the right way just
statistics of you surviving are very
good if not the human species wouldn't
have continued the women that survived
to have children were ones that
descended from ones that survived to
have children they can't have children
yeah a woman can't have children they're
just like any other animal other animals
die in the shadow bird too they do but
not as well I don't know if it's the
reason because Mom is the head it's the
head you're right I don't know if you
guys know this but the the human head
the baby head pretty big that's about as
big as it can get and it's because of
our big ass brains yeah
um is is what kills a lot of women in
childbirth because
the brain and it's not that's also the
reason why uh babies have to be taken
care of for so long which you don't
usually see in the animal kingdom it's
like usually you know they they squeeze
out the babies the babies are kind of
helpless for a little bit but not for
that long they usually figure [__] out
like but but human babies you know you
got to take care of them for like years
and years and that's because the head
the baby head that's as big as it can go
because it can't if it gets any bigger
then it would kill every woman that it
was like trying to come out of because
our hips can't get any wider baby's
head's kind of flexible though it is
it's squishy well that's yeah it's like
when they're born they still have that
the fontanelle like on top and it's like
it's still it's not fused in the middle
but still I mean
baby heads are giant it just still like
blows my mind that that like [__]
[__] comes out of there I've seen it
happen but they had women back in the
ancient days you know 9 10 11 kids no
problem just squeeze them out run that
right after one right after another
but then they have other ones that they
died for the first child they die well
yeah like I said it depends on a lot of
things because a lot of things can go
wrong and like I said a lot of things go
wrong nowadays too like but nowadays
they can usually catch it if you have
good health care
um you know which I know some people
don't but that's the thing it's a
numbers game
well yeah but uh nature is a number I
mean that's easy to say when it's like
not you that you're talking about you
know what I mean like when it's when
it's me then I'm just gonna be like yeah
I give a [__] about that like I can say
that so so statistics all I want I'm
thinking about all those women along the
whole track like looking at it for
Scientology over the thousands of years
oh God don't bring that yeah yeah they
mostly make it
yeah
that's yeah it's [__] up but it but I
mean
there there can be fewer I think badass
things that just like popping out a kid
and then going to fights and Pirates
yeah like a couple hours later that's
like pretty rad I gotta say
so yeah
now uh so okay so what happened at this
point like I said this was during like
right around the period of like the the
nine years war between the English and
the Irish
now Elizabeth the first had come into
power
and uh as I said they were trying to I
guess they were trying to like take over
Ireland or like tame the Irish whatever
it was they were trying to do and as I
mentioned earlier one of the things that
they would do was doing like a divide
and conquer type of thing and Elizabeth
the first was kind of I don't know if
she was the engineer of this but she was
for sure uh you know into like doing it
is they would
they wanted to like suppress certain
Irish Clans that were more trouble than
they were worth let's put it that way so
they would kind of like give favors and
land and [__] like that to other Irish
Clans that would [__] up the Troublesome
Irish Clans you know what I mean so they
would kind of like so Discord within
Ireland they would do that kind of stuff
um you know
so uh so basically there's you know like
I said the Irish really really did not
like they did not want to be under
English Rule and they did not like the
English encroaching on them in this
fashion
um but indeed the English were
encroaching farther and farther
now in around
1578 I believe it was there was a guy
called The Earl of Desmond
and he decided because as I said Grace
O'Malley or grania O'Malley was um quite
famous and was seen as I guess like a
little bit of something of a
troublemaker
so um he actually had grania arrested
and she was put in prison in Limerick
for about a year I think they actually
moved her to Dublin later on
and she got I've heard two stories I've
heard she was late she was released
because uh of good behavior but I've
also heard that she escaped so I don't
know which one of those things is true
um it is true though that she was well
she had kind of like I don't know about
a friend but she had like a sympathetic
person whose name was Sir Henry Sydney
and he was the Lord Deputy of Ireland
and um he had actually met her and her
son a few years previously and again was
a great admirer of hers so he I guess he
maybe like engineered or helped out that
she could get out
um you know so but people helped her get
out like I said because she was well
known and uh respected like particularly
around Ireland
um and there were also some English
Aristocrats who admired her as well so
she even had you know even among their
quote-unquote enemies uh she had that as
well
so basically okay so as I said what they
were trying to do they were trying to
bring Ireland under English law which
meant getting rid of the whole Chieftain
Clan system which the Irish had been
doing for however long you know hundreds
hundreds and hundreds of years
um you know again in the Irish we're not
happy about this
now in 1584 there's a guy uh an English
guy named Sir Richard Bingham and he
became Lord president of conact I guess
I'm pronouncing that I'm sure I'm
pronouncing that wrong but it's like
that's probably close enough
and he started
um trying to get rid of the whole
Chieftain system by basically doing I
mean he would do raids he would do I
don't know if I'd say genocide but he
would go in there and like wipe people
out
um and then he would do like some other
stuff like he would bribe people and do
like I said divide and conquer type [__]
that kind of stuff
so uh so that's what he was doing at
this point
now Sir Richard Bingham was kind of like
I guess you could you could call him
gronya O'Malley's like Nemesis like the
dude was
um they they were kind of at loggerheads
like later on right so this whole thing
that was happening
uh grania did not like the [__] that he
was doing so she basically
uh started like rebelling against him
along her and along with others
and because of this
uh Bingham
actually murdered her son Owen one of
her sons
and uh her son with iron Richard Tibbett
um also imprisoned him and her other son
Murrow like by her first husband and
also imprisoned granya's half-brother
now he also arrested guanya herself but
she um got out somehow
but her sons and her half-brother are
still in prison and Owen was murdered
like her son so she's a little bit
um
a bit aggravated by this she's a little
bit annoyed by this all her sons are in
prison and one of them is dead so you
know what I mean
um now gronya even though prior to this
like when her when her shipwreck lover
dude got killed she just went went to
the castle and like wiped out the
[__] that did it but this time around
I think she thought maybe
that politics would be better so what
she decided to do
was she said well I'm gonna go this
Bingham [__] he works for
essentially Queen Elizabeth
so I'm gonna go over his head I'm gonna
go right to Elizabeth the First and I'm
gonna talk to her so that's what she did
so she basically like broke I don't know
like she wrote to her petitioned her or
whatever like to come see her
so basically what happens so they bring
gronya in I don't know how long a period
it was before like she asked for an
audience and like how long it was prior
to that
but they bring her in and she dress up
all nice and everything like that and um
they asked her like a series of 18
questions and this is like apparently on
record uh with the English records and
so she had to like write all this stuff
out
and so she comes in to meet Queen
Elizabeth
and one thing that she did and I love
that she did this and didn't get in
trouble
she would not bow to her
like you're supposed to because she
thought well we are equals
well she's the pirate Queen that's what
they called her
so she was like [__] that I mean it was
which is a very Irish that's a very
Irish dish like I'm bound to you
[__] I'm the same as you are I'm
a queen too right yeah and yes she well
like I said she saw them as equals so
she's like I'm not bowing to her [__]
that are there any descriptions of what
she looked like there is a wood cut of
her meeting Queen Elizabeth yeah
um but it's kind of hard yeah it's hard
to tell like what she looked like I
think this is just symbolic probably for
the people that made those woodcuts
probably never saw the original person
there's a description of her though not
really I've heard that um
probably big old fat girl how much I bet
well why would she be a big fat girl
because she's got all that kind of money
and she went people's asses and probably
well fed I'm sure as well
I don't know how much in those days how
much fighting and like seafaring you
yeah
back in those days she's out
swashbuckling and [__] she couldn't be
fat she was big fine I bet she you're
just you're just wishing
she's a BBW she's like yeah how much I
bet I don't know they probably would
have thought that was very attractive
because maybe most people were skinny
yeah that's true it's like Cowboys
Cowboys like fat girls
you know that yeah yeah all you gotta do
is look at the saloon paintings that
they had a big old fagger they liked big
fine because they didn't see that they
just saw scrawny people
well yeah because everyone was like
[__] eating heart attack and [__]
yeah being fat was like the cowboy
version of like having booty and
implants
yeah you could well you may it looked
like you had some money
because you could feed yourself well fit
like I said everybody else I don't but I
don't know they call that shapely sure
yeah we call it fat but they call it
shaving yeah well it's it is a shape
when I was in the Army we had Cowboy
dudes they like fat girls too they're
still into that
skinny Cowboy dudes with the [__]
hats and the [__] belts yeah the
[__] thing in their belt going down
almost down like halfway down their
[__] thigh like it was their dicks or
something
and they're going with a little fat girl
in a truck
[Laughter]
300 pound girl
yeah
yeah never know for that [__] man yeah
yeah but yeah we'll get on you Islanders
too man with all the myelin boys they're
like the big girls too yeah
yeah hey nothing wrong with that
everybody likes what they like you know
what I mean it takes all kinds of
micronesians and [__] Samoans and
Hawaiians
they like fat girls man
that look like well fed yeah then you're
with us it may not go to the club again
no man I'm not going so why don't you
come to the club man nah the girls are
too skinny
[Laughter]
really because yeah
I'm smart we're like fat girls
[Laughter]
but yeah so um so not only did granier
refuse to bow to Queen Elizabeth
apparently according to Legend they also
searched her and found a dagger on her
but she was like oh no man I need that
for my own protection and Elizabeth said
no it's fine yeah like and they just let
her in there because like I said
Elizabeth it seems like at least from
the records that survive was kind of
fascinated by her because like I said at
this point they were both about the same
age they were both in their 50s like
when they met well she wanted me some
other chick that had some Mojo yeah I
think the thing well because Elizabeth I
mean she'd kind of been a royal her
whole entire life she'd kind of been
groomed if you want to use that word
like to you know to be the queen and all
this other kind of stuff so she didn't
have I mean I'm not saying oh poor her
or anything like that because obviously
she had all the money and it's like I
don't feel sorry for her in any way but
in a lot of ways their lives were very
constrained like they you know they had
all these rituals they had to do they
had all the stuff they had to do and
everything like that
um and I think she was fascinated by
granya because granya just did whatever
the [__] she pleased like she didn't
seem to have any the interesting thing
about her is that she she seemed to like
not just do whatever she wanted but she
didn't really seem to have any sanctions
about that like nobody seemed to get all
up in her case about
um her not doing what women were
supposed to do I mean she did do [__]
that she was supposed to do like she did
married like for strategic purposes
she'd have kids she did all that other
kind of stuff but
she mostly it seems like just did
whatever the hell she wanted and she ran
[__] and people were like fine with it
yeah you know what I mean call it the
Polynesians are coming out of the
woodwork now yeah U.S Polynesian women
love thick love thick women yeah yeah
that's what he said yeah yeah that's
what you said
but yeah so um so they had like a nice
little uh chat the two of them
and uh apparently they conducted the
whole entire meeting in Latin uh because
that was the only language they had in
common
um you know because obviously uh Queen
Elizabeth did not speak Irish and uh
granya
one thing I said said that she either
could not or would not speak English uh
so they conducted the whole thing in
Latin
yeah right
um so they talked for quite a while
and granya was able to persuade the
queen even though Bingham worked for
Queen Elizabeth
she was able to persuade the queen that
um her sons should be released and that
Bingham would get the [__] off her case
like would stop his you know Campaign Of
Terror against her like he'd already
killed one of her sons but you know what
I mean obviously that couldn't be taken
back but you know so Elizabeth actually
did go to Bingham like gave
gave grania a letter that said give this
to Bingham and it says you have to let
like the captives go and all this other
kind of stuff which I'm sure grania
loved that here [__] that's from
the queen
so I thought that was very funny now one
thing and like I said I think this is
where the whole story about gronya like
collaborating with the English crown
went
um I think one of the things that gronya
did was she said oh well in return I
will give you
um like a bunch of my ships and 200 men
um to help you like keep peace in
Ireland right that's what she said
and um she never did that [__] though
which I thought was really funny so like
I said it's not like she was
collaborating with she was just trying
to get her kids out of jail is what she
was trying to do I don't think she
really gave a [__]
um one way or the other about the
conflict I mean yeah she really cared a
lot about Irish Independence because she
did
um you know give ships to like some
Rebels and stuff like that in that
regard but she was just saying whatever
she needed to say like to get what she
wanted she's like yeah I'll totally give
you all these ships and these dudes like
to help you like quell rebellions in
Ireland and stuff like that but she
never did it she never did it
um but yeah so Elizabeth did give her
this letter and uh you know so she had
to go give it to Bingham
now Bingham because he sounds like a
real dick
um he decides he's like oh well I guess
the queen said I have to but he's gonna
drag his [__] feet right so he
doesn't like let the prisoners out until
a while because he argued to the queen
and I hate to say it but he was correct
that he's like she's not gonna do what
she said she was gonna do she's not
gonna give you all those ships and those
dudes and everything like that and he
was right about that she didn't that
would have been wasted probably her
advisor says you can't give her that
yeah those ships will never come back
they'll all be wasted in Foreign Wars I
don't think she I don't think Rania had
any intention of giving those ships or
those men to the English crown at all I
think she just said that because she
wanted like I said she wanted her sons
out of jail okay and I think that was
she was just using that as leverage oh
I'll give you all this stuff and I don't
think she had any intention of um of
honoring that agreement and I think you
know as much of a douche as Bingham
sounds like um he was right about that
because that's why he took him so long
he's like I'm not letting these
prisoners out because she's not gonna do
that [__] she's not gonna give us the
ships or the men and she didn't but he
did eventually like um
yeah yeah
um so yeah so like I said she did end up
giving some ships later on to uh the
Irish rebel forces so she did do that so
it did seem like she did give a [__]
about the cause of Irish Independence
although she didn't I think some Legend
said that she had actually fought in the
nine years war herself I don't think she
actually did at least not directly but
she did actually give support to like a
lot of the Irish Rebels so there's that
so um basically they don't really know
like the last decade of her life
um they don't really know much about her
they there are records of a uh petition
that she sent in 1595 and she was
actually complaining about English
troops that had um that were quartered
on her land and she was not happy about
it so they do have that survives so they
do know that
um they think she died in 1603 which is
the same year that Queen Elizabeth died
coincidentally and they think she
probably died at Rock Fleet Castle which
was um the castle where she probably
spent the last 10 years of her life and
so
um I've heard also that she kept on
pirating like until she was in her 70s
like up until she almost
like almost until her death so like I
said kind of a badass out there like an
elderly lady
out there
pirate and pirate and ships having
babies killing Pirates having babies in
her seven having the babies in her 70s
no that's not true yeah but yeah so um
so basically like I said the what is she
doing books up no no look then she in
defiance she just does it harder yeah
she doesn't she's she's uh she's
incorrigible that one I complained about
it she just started ripping harder she's
like yeah screw you Dad yeah yeah what
are you doing
she makes a face like look at me like
what stop it
turn it up okay but yeah so they
actually didn't really even write the
definitive biography of her until 1979
and that was written by a woman named
Ann Chambers and I think after that
biography came out because I kind of
feel like prior to that
um
she had largely been
not completely forgotten because she
still lived on and like a lot of
folklore I think there's like a lot of
there's some Irish ballads like about
her and stuff like that
but I feel like she wasn't really known
much outside of Ireland you know what
I'm saying like she's not famous the way
like Anne Bonnie is famous or like the
way some other Pirates are maybe famous
so
I don't know so so like I said I didn't
see I did find like a couple
documentaries about her like on YouTube
and stuff like that but not really that
many and I hadn't actually heard of her
until somebody recommended her like a
while so um
if you actually go by if you actually go
by the rule book she's not she wasn't a
pirate she was never she never assigned
a privateer contract well I one of the
sources I um that I read said
that Elizabeth did actually give her a
contract a contract okay
um for pirating okay then she was apart
but yeah so like just like Sir Francis
Drake and [__] like that happened so I
don't like I said I don't know if that's
true or not but I think that that was
one of the things that Elizabeth most of
the time this was freelance stuff that
she's doing yeah
under the Irish flag if there is such a
thing there probably was no Irish flag
back there just Clans
yeah yeah
but um but yeah so I kind of feel like
in the last probably
10 20 30 years interest in her is really
seems like it's you know gotten a lot
more yeah whereas you know I feel like
she's been forgotten prior to that was
Ireland actually unified at that time I
don't believe so yeah okay I don't
believe so now like I said it was
basically just a loose conglomeration of
Clans clans that all had you know they
right they had like enemies and right
collaborations and so it's not like you
could you could uh pirate or Privateer
for the Irish Crown there wasn't one
yeah there was no such thing yeah but
I'm pretty sure that Elizabeth gave her
that like permission yeah like you can
go pirating so they would have been like
the federal government at the time kind
of
Ben said Ireland was a confederation of
kingdoms with a high King who was
largely a figurehead okay around this
time like I said this is
late 1500s is when this was all going on
stop it Pokey man
you are defiant are you Irish
the the world's only Irish cat well
Irish American she's a Manx so that's
Scottish right I think so which I guess
is similar you are an Irish lady you're
like a damn gummy bear she does look
like a Gummy Bear yeah
one thing that she does she jumps up on
my counter in the bathroom and I have
like this kind of um ceramic uh like
thing like jar thing and it has like
this metal
uh decorative doohickey like on the on
the top on the lid and she just loves to
chew that and I don't really like her
chewing it because she's gonna break her
damn teeth it's metal yeah and so she'll
jump up on there and I'm brushing her
and I can see her little eyes like going
to that she just can't resist it yeah
and she just very slowly kind of
saunters over there and I'm brushing and
then she kind of goes and she's like I'm
just I'm just rubbing on it I'm just
rubbing I'm not and then like when she
thinks I'm not looking like she's like
and then like and then I'm like and then
I'm like
like that and I'm just like no yeah and
then she looks at me in the mirror and
she makes a little mad face yeah
she knows what no is she doesn't like no
at all she absolutely designed yeah yeah
like she does not like to be she is like
she is like a bratty yeah like
four-year-old even though she's she's
six
yeah I guess she's she's six years old
yeah but um she is very much like like a
recalcitrant toddler she just like does
not yeah it's a trip she does not like
to be told no yeah like she'll
grudgingly stop sometimes when you tell
her because she knows what no means and
she'll just like okay but then she waits
until you understand why you're telling
her no right she's just like what the
[__] yeah
she wants to tear up any kind of leather
boot or leather shoes so you got to keep
her away from gotta lock all the boot
Boots the boots and the shoes and you
open up the closet she sneaks in there
and lays down next to him like I'm not
gonna do it I'm not gonna do it I'm just
laying here when you think she's not
looking she goes
yeah you try to fool me but I know what
you're doing yeah I think she doesn't
she tries to deceive she tries I think
she doesn't quite understand that we can
hear her yeah like like we know what
that noise is yeah because she tries to
act all slick yeah like when you're not
she'll do it when you're not looking but
then when you turn around she's like
yeah like she acts all natural like she
wasn't doing anything and looks kind of
guilty it's hard to believe that a cat
is capable
I'm trying to play it off I wasn't doing
it I told you the funniest thing that
she ever did in that regard was we had
those Little Sheba meat sticks that she
likes and we keep them in the um in the
side table like the um nightstand
and she knows where they are so about
the same time every night she'll toddle
on over and like sit there next to the
drawer and like look up at daddy like
meatstick time and the rule is that she
can't have a new one until she finishes
the old one because when you give her an
old when you give her one one you have
to sit there and hold it like in your
hand if you drop it on the floor she
gets mad and she runs out she's like you
ruined it yeah so you have to sit there
and hold it until she eats it and
sometimes she'll just like sit there and
lick it and like not eat it and it takes
forever and it takes forever yeah so
then sometimes too like she'll bite it
down to the end and then obviously you
have to like Drop it because you can't
you know there's no room left and she'll
bite you in the finger yeah [__] that I
don't want that and then she'll run off
and then like later on she'll come back
and want another one and there's still
like a piece of one like on the floor
and Tom's like you have to eat that
first before I mean and she knows what
that means too it's like you have to eat
that before you get a new one yeah and I
know that she knows what that means
because sometimes she'll come in and
very deliberately sit on it so you can't
see it yeah
look up at you with that cute little
face like it's time for a new one yeah
there's nothing no push her off and I'll
point it that one she goes oh [__] I got
busted
I tried to hide and then she'll eat it
but it's like this it's so funny that
she [__] does that and like you said
that is indicative of higher reasoning
higher functioning you have to be pretty
smart to like try to deceive someone
else even though she's not super good at
it like obviously we know that she sat
on the thing because obviously but the
fact that she would even think to do
that and like think she could get away
with it yeah is like very very funny
yeah it was obvious to me because she's
walking up to me and I saw a little
piece on the ground and she gets it and
it stands on it that wasn't there I saw
you it's like oh okay you got it she's
trying to get a new one it's like that
was so [__] funny yeah yeah she only
tried it once yeah I mean but still
um all right so I guess how long have
you been on just like an hour long time
yeah yeah it's good John Gore said Italy
didn't become a unified thing until like
the 1910s or something yeah it was like
it was frilly recently and I remember
hearing that and like that kind of
blowing my mind but yeah yeah Germany
was in a bunch of pieces to like the 30s
wasn't it yeah they didn't get their
[__] figured out yeah like way later on
all right I guess we're gonna wrap it up
because I gotta go to bed soon and all
that other kind of stuff so anyway
hopefully you guys found this story
about grania O'Malley as fascinating as
I did uh one of the few female pirates I
guess
so uh yeah so thanks to I can't remember
who it was so I apologize for that like
who it was that recommended it cause it
was a long time ago but uh thank you for
recommending that because I probably
never would have
come to it on my own and I actually
ended up being uh I thought it was like
a really interesting story so you know
what I mean
um all right so yeah Germany wasn't
unified until 1989 that's right yeah
that's right and uh what's his face from
Knight Rider did it yeah
yeah very good
David Hasselhoff for Unified
yeah what I was talking about those I
was talking about you know Germany kind
of reunified the ride and they said that
that was now greater Germany and there
were german-speaking people in there I
don't know if that actually counted and
I think he I think he I think he merged
Germany and Austria together
which I don't know what I don't I don't
know I don't I don't think Austria
considered itself to be Germany maybe
most of the people there didn't but I
think it was even prior to like early
1900s like prior to World War one I
think Germany was in a bunch of pieces
out of it I don't know I gotta go I
don't really know the history that well
a lot of it remember the Ottoman Empire
where the was really the main player
during that time
yeah
all right so I guess we're going to wrap
it up for this awesome Hungarian Empire
too yeah right I'm gonna wrap it up for
this evening yeah so uh be sure to drop
by again Friday night for the Sidetrack
show where we're just gonna drink and
fart around and talk about whatever so
that should always be fun
so yeah uh please remember to like share
subscribe comment all of that other kind
of stuff and we will see you guys again
on Friday night good night